i got a new phone right and i saw all
the comments like oh my god i kind of
got the pixel six already i got it day
one right you're a fake fan getting
there so my last phone as some you guys
know and i've some sort of complaint
about it i had the pixel 4 before i was
dying yeah and i got this phone
everyone's like how is it connor it's
good it's also really [ __ ] why why
there's so many annoying things that
like i don't know why like okay so
so okay you guys know me big fan of my
chromecast i think we're all aware i
love my chromecast yeah
sorry
it's your most used appliances
right so yeah exactly so i go to my bed
right and i'm like oh the volume is too
loud let me turn it down
okay normally i would just like press
the volume button on my phone when it's
being cached to the tv and it would go
down yeah it isn't doing it that's weird
okay maybe it was just like this there's
a one-off and then it doesn't happen
again it doesn't happen again turns out
uh yeah it's like an intended feature
they just removed it and then i was like
why and then apparently there was like
it's a legal issue i'm like it's a legal
issue for me to turn my volume up and
down what's going on what's going on is
it to stop people at parties from like
turning the volume too high maybe i i
don't i don't think why would that be a
legal issue that's a that's a dickish
friend issue you know i was like
has google been taking uh notes of apple
or something just like
guys guys this is an intended issue you
know what you're not i i think i'm still
like the the only person left in [ __ ]
2021 that makes that misses the [ __ ]
auxiliary
auxiliary [ __ ] bro
sometimes sometimes you need it
sometimes you [ __ ] need it sometimes
sometimes kids today will never know the
choices
the reason why we don't have progress in
humanity he holds on to the artifacts of
old i'm sorry that sometimes you like
you go in an old car or something that
doesn't have bluetooth connectivity i'm
sorry that not everyone owns a [ __ ]
tesla or something you know
some some that makes its own music yeah
some people our age are still [ __ ]
broke and their radios or their [ __ ]
music play knees and knocks everything i
missed the day when i could say yo pass
me the orcs
i can't say that [ __ ] anymore dude
i gotta be like you pass me the
bluetooth like my brother had the same
problem you know when his first car he
had the cassettes only that would go
into oh hell yeah so he had to get a
cassette to aux cable
and that was really cool though just
seeing how like how it worked i don't
know i don't understand that that's
going to come back in a couple years
time it's going to be cassette to
bluetooth yeah it's like a bluetooth
cassette pop in yeah
uh progress no no no no no i'm i'm not
the one halting progress this is yeah
this is the corporations selling us like
they're like they're making an issue and
then they they're selling they're
selling us the solution
like have you seen the apple are now
like adding more ports
even though the people who remove the
ports are apple themselves so they're
just like apple
let me show you on this okay let's let's
create an issue ourselves
and then let's sell the solution to our
customers and frame it as a solution
that we didn't make in the first place
like what what genius that's true but i
really hope that everything just goes
usbc as well i'm i'm just i want
everything to be the [ __ ] saying yeah
and thank god that yeah thank god europe
is like hey apple [ __ ] you
do usbc we don't care if you're right
we're in europe
i like it i you know as much as uh you
know yeah proprietary technology and all
that [ __ ] it's like just it wouldn't it
be nice if it's like can i borrow your
charger you have to ask what charger do
you have yeah what a society we would
live in bro what's that mean with that
the flying spaceships and this like yeah
civilization this is civilization this
is where we would have been if everyone
agreed on usb-c like years ago that's
literally like we you know it's just
basically everyone and then apple which
is just how things are but also usb
definitely suffered from all that [ __ ] a
while back as well with micro b and
micro oh yeah yeah yeah
and then usbc came along and everyone's
like this is [ __ ] and then i was like
hold up it's actually it's actually not
that bad it's good yeah you can plug it
in either way
it just works and where people were just
like what you can do that it's solved an
issue
but yeah i know i think uh buying this
phone was good i like the camera that's
that's all that's good about it you know
you know
yeah going back on the like auxiliary
thing and just proprietary things that i
miss it's just a lot of the times i
don't really see a point in buying a new
phone i i normally just buy a new phone
most of the time because the battery the
battery life just gets [ __ ] right but i
was completely fine with my old phone
if if the battery if the battery life
hadn't reduced over time i would have
still kept my old phone because
what are what new features are you using
your new phone for that you're not using
your own old phone i will say one thing
this is just a youtuber thing
being able to have a somewhat good
camera in your pocket if i need some
b-roll or something or i need like a
little vlog bit is super useful that's
that's the only reason why i update it
to the new iphone just the camera on
that i don't i don't have to log around
a huge dslr all the time and also i'm a
big tech nerd right so i want to get the
new stuff
so the fact that it lines up is like a
justifiable reason in my mind for work
it's like a it's like a no-brainer for
me like i'm gonna do it now this is the
first year in like five years where i i
had i didn't upgrade my phone after one
year yeah i waited really yeah i know i
normally i did it every year i don't
know why i just found that i must have
been buying [ __ ] phones that kept
getting actually i used my phone a lot
yeah like more than the average person
i'd say i'm playing videos on it
non-stop
and uh yeah this time i waited two years
and i i really felt it in the last year
because like my god was my phone being
[ __ ] yeah but what was it what was being
[ __ ] about it uh battery was the main
issue obviously yeah i mean that's
always the main issue but i was
definitely getting like the cpu slow
down issue where like stuff was getting
slow
sometimes i would press the lock screen
button and more often than not it just
wouldn't open
and then sometimes it would open but
then i've been pressing it so much that
now it was buffering all the opening and
and that i was trying to do and it would
like just start spazzing out so
a lot of issues
here it does happen tonight are you dead
it definitely does happen
i've had iphones i
i literally had an iphone and then i
switched to samsung because i was like
encountering too many different issues
the reason why i changed to android is
because my my iphone was just being so
[ __ ] temperamental like it was
breaking so much that was the opposite
for me my samsung phone was being so
[ __ ] that i changed back to an iphone i
guess it depends like on which phone you
get right this is like i think the last
one i got was like the six iphone six
yeah that was quite a while ago yeah
yeah but then that's because i i done
iphone four five and six
and i was getting more and more annoyed
with each generation like [ __ ] this yeah
fair enough and i just i just like i
just like the customized customizability
that you have with the server it's
really easy to like as well download
apps that you aren't supposed to on
android that
hey do you want to just like
like do a criminal offense in some
countries and ward your warranty a
warranty in every other country uh by
jailbreaking it it's like you know it
kind of sucks i you know and sometimes
you don't i don't want to show i didn't
want to jailbreak it i just wanted one
thing that i had to jailbreak it for and
i was like okay well [ __ ]
i just didn't jailbreak at the end
because i was like i'm a good boy fine
it's just like just download the apk and
then install it yeah is uh that phone
bigger than your last phone because i
noticed it was like chunky boy when i
held it yes yeah it's the chunk chart i
like the visor though i like this like
daft punk
is it not it's got like mad deaf punk
vibes i like that see i wasn't it looks
kind of like a moccasin
i know it doesn't look like [ __ ]
among get the [ __ ] out of here this does
not look like i can't be the
deep breath does that who this is that
yeah deep breath give me a give me a
mongoose skin yeah a red skin humongous
skin
overall right you know i was i've been
waiting for the pixel six for like i was
like i'd watch everything like why
because like i i i got sucked up into
that like you know i'd watch the marcus
brown lee's i'd watch the whoever else
there was everyone who isn't marcus
brownlee because no one else is like you
know marcus brown
that's how it is with youtubers it's
like marcus brownlee linus tech tips
everybody else to the normies right yeah
i know there's other people i'm just i
mean i'm just joking but like austin
evans crying right yeah yeah
but that's the thing right my mom can
watch marcus brownlee my mum likes
marcus brownlee's videos right and and i
don't know what it is because somehow he
makes tech very approachable to like
absolutely anybody yeah like when i
watch learners tech tips it's good but
it's definitely for someone who like
likes their tech yeah yeah you have to
have knowledge um and like there are
some other ones as well who are decent
but i think marcus browning somehow just
gets the perfect balance of like
appealing to like enthusiasts
would but also appealing to like my mom
yeah
yeah i don't know so that's how that's
probably why he's just so successful
there as well yeah i mean like when i
was like
gonna upgrade my phone i was like should
i should i move away from samsung and i
like started watching a lot of tech
videos like comparison videos which is
the best phone to get in 2021 and then i
watched like several like [ __ ] 20
minute long videos comparing like the
samsung to the iphone or the pixel one
yeah so let's see
and then i realized i have no idea what
any of these guys are talking about yeah
and like the difference that i'm gonna
find is gonna be minuscule with
everything i've just found out that with
most of those videos at the end of it
all they'll give you all these like tech
rundowns of like yeah it's better in the
iphone but better on the samsung but
then at the end you'll just be like yeah
so uh which one's better it really
depends on what you want to use the
phone for really uh it's up to you yeah
the samsung is like 0.5 better at taking
pictures at night time so if you're
going to take pictures at night and i'm
just like if you're a night photographer
only
here in my mind i'm just like well i've
never taken pictures at night but maybe
i'm going to start in the next year you
know this is this might be something i
need to like pay attention to and i'm
just like and then after like
overloading myself with information i
just realized none of this actually
[ __ ] matters all that matters is the
[ __ ] price point and the [ __ ]
your personal choice and your personal
choice clearly the camera clearly
doesn't [ __ ] matter because every
single video of any public event with a
camera ever seems to be in 360p so like
clearly the people who are at these like
[ __ ] walmart fights don't have the
newest iphone filming in 4k hdr because
that's i i don't see these fights in 4k
that's true yeah people aren't uploading
tick tocks and like [ __ ] 8k
resolution although our phones can shoot
ak resolution i don't know when we'd
ever use it you know what's weird is
that i've had so uh my last phone was a
pixel 4 right before that had the
oneplus
7 pro yeah which everyone had the camera
that like manually came out like it was
a motor but the camera came out oh yeah
yeah yeah and to this day that's still
like the best camera i used to filming
oh my phone
it was better than my pixel 4 and it i
think it's still better than this
because it can do 4k right and it can
you can change all the settings like
in in the camera yeah
i had to buy new phones when i moved to
japan oneplus doesn't work in japan
because japan has its own type of
frequency waves or something that it
uses but no other country uses we're not
like the others yeah so so if you want
to buy a phone you you know make sure i
i'm pretty sure like none of the chinese
phones work in japan no that's not true
really i used a huawei phone here
it works yeah oh okay well oneplus
doesn't work so there's a few other ones
in particular i think like i think oppo
phones i don't see them ever here they
do sell them really yeah i've seen
phones i wonder is it just [ __ ] one plus
then it's literally just [ __ ] one time
okay to be fair i hadn't heard of
oneplus until you bought one and you
started raving about it i i i've never
heard of to be fair when i had it way
back it was really good yeah and then
recently their phones have been coming
you are the only person i've ever known
that's owned a oneplus okay if somebody
owns a oneplus they're normally like
they follow like tech stuff because it's
definitely like a tech person phone or
at least it was like it was like it was
like really good specs and stuff
for a good price right and then now they
just do what everyone else is doing just
like good specs for high prices so that
doesn't [ __ ] fair enough yeah i mean
that's just like that's i'm not i don't
pay too much attention to the tech world
i like i pay attention when i need to
buy something new yeah it's the problem
with that's the one with phones right
like you you i as much as i think like
the galaxy fold looks sick it's like i
didn't want to buy a phone at that time
and then by the time i i want to get a
phone i probably want to get one that's
newer so that i'm not getting away is
the galaxy fault even worth it what's
what looks sick
what's holding your phone that's the
unique selling point apart from just it
falls
imagine the power move where you text
someone and you [ __ ] slam your phone
right afterwards you're like [ __ ] this
person like
[ __ ] that's the same thing with the
motorola they they came up with the new
smartphone as well where you can just
like it's basically a football but it's
just
a fashion piece it's a fashionable yeah
but like so is everything in your
[ __ ] life
well that's why apple makes so much
money right it's yeah yeah even though i
like there's some things that apple make
that i don't like like i have have you
seen have you seen the conference video
of when apple announced the price of
their monitor um
that was pretty ridiculous that felt
like that should have been like the
website yeah
just let it pop up
you know when you're making a
presentation and you know you know the
audience isn't going to be happy and
it's like us and uh so the monitor arm
is uh can be priced at 999 and uh moving
on and uh it's like like
you can just tell how nervous he was and
how much he had to like
like mentally rehearse that in his mind
before he set it out loud it was like me
listing my christmas list to my mom when
i was a child it's uh 200 anyway the
other one is ten dollars